Taylor Swift is making worlds converge
she's already generating tons of birds
by attending Kansas City Chiefs games
but now she's got Marvel fans
speculating about whether she'll be a
movie mutant sometime soon Taylor
Swift's relationship with pro football
star Travis Kelsey seemingly a romance
has sparked interest in the sport among
swifties the pop star is shared for him
at several Kansas City Chiefs games but
her latest appearance of some Marvel
Heavy Hitters has pure speculation about
a possible superhero role for the
anti-hero singer Swift attended the
October 1st Chiefs Jets game at MetLife
Stadium with an Entourage in tow
including bestie Blake Lively Lively's
husband Ryan Reynolds Hugh Jackman and
director Sean Levy Reynolds and
Jacqueline will share the screen as
Deadpool and Wolverine in the upcoming
Deadpool 3 with Levy directing they
could all just be friends hanging out
but there's also a chance Reynolds could
work some magic and get Swift apart in
the three quality X-Men's resident pop
star that's the theory being spouted by
accounts like media verse comics and
raps on Ax formerly known as Twitter the
Fang community site posted okay so
seemingly Taylor Swift as dazzler in
Deadpool 3 it's all just a rumor at the
moment but the pieces could be falling
in place for the Swifty and Marvel
fandoms to unite Reynolds has already
proven himself to be Adept at getting
A-list cameos in his superhero movies
Deadpool 2 features blinking your missed
appearances from Brad Pitt and Matt
Damon so Taylor Swift and Deadpool 3
wouldn't be out of the question
especially considering how close Swift
is with Blake Lively Reynolds has
fielded questions about Swift's
involvement before although he denied
rumors of a swift cameo in Deadpool 3 to
Entertainment Tonight in November 2022
he added that he would certainly support
such an idea
of course yeah
didn't do anything for that woman she's
or remember from the media coverage
leading up to Spider-Man no way home to
just because an actor tells a reporter
something isn't happening in an MCU
movie does not necessarily mean that
thing isn't happening and Swift wouldn't
even be the first major pop star to show
up in the quintessential shared film and
TV Universe For Better or Worse her ex
Harry Styles memorably Cameo as a
flamboyant Cosmic being Eros AKA Star
Fox in 2021's eternals Reynolds never
mentioned any specific character Swift
could play but she's been funcasted as
doesla AKA Alison Blair sends all the
way back to her visit to the set of
X-Men apocalypse in 2016. in the comics
dazzler is generally affiliated with the
X-Men and juggles her singing career
with her duties as a superhero with the
power to convert sound into concussive
blasts of light it's the perfect role
for Swift especially with how crowded
Deadpool 3 is shaping up to be Jennifer
Garner will reportedly return as a
lecturer in the film and there are
rumors the likes of Halle Berry and
Patrick Stewart could return to the
roles of storm and Professor X and Sean
Levy has hinted at some surprise cameos
could be installed for fans telling
Entertainment Weekly the rumors of
actors singers sports stars who are all
apparently in Deadpool 3 are fabulous if
all I read was the internet I would have
the greatest cast ever assembled in the
history of Cinema so I'll simply say
that some of those rumors are true and
some of them aren't given how successful
The Cinematic release of Taylor Swift
the iris tour is expected to be could be
a good idea from a financial perspective
to get her involved as Travis Kelsey and
the Kansas City Chiefs are quickly
learning the Taylor Swift bump is very
real what happened on Sunday makes him
the most famous player in the NFL like
that
foreign
[Music]